no i can't i can't i can't hi i'm emily
hey i'm tucker and today we're trying
japanese snacks
yeah let's make fangirl want to use a
scallop for accuracy using the same
amount of silken tofu and 50 grams of
sugar and i don't want this be sweet
when it's sweeter just add your sugar
now just mix this really well add red
food coloring and matcha powder to the
other and roll these into little balls
like this
drop in some boiling water oil for one
minute now lower the heat and then cover
for four minutes i'll float to the top
when ready add two like that
they look like easter eggs they do they
do look easy i'd never known what that
emoji was but now i've learned they look
good are they they're not mochi though
they're like
tofu tofu you just taught me about tofu
and you don't even know but they look
yummy i would definitely eat them they
look like a food i would like to play
with though like i kind of want to throw
one at somebody like they're snowball
shaped i'm envisioning me throwing one
at you and i like the way it looks in my
head
it looks like there's like some sort of
like strawberry or like raspberry jam
what is this called
dongo tonka that sounds so good
are you eating the whole thing i guess
you are okay
[Music]
do you hate it
it tastes a lot like milk
no i can't i can't i can't
okay the outside i was like mochi and
then once i bit inside i was like what
is this it kind of reminds me of boba
it was the texture it was like a weird
texture for me and i didn't love the
flavor also yeah i'm like shocked i
don't like it i'm italian but i flock
towards japanese food actually quite a
bit what's the middle
middle
i'm getting rice and as someone who eats
rice every single day because i'm
dominican i like it yeah it's like the
texture of the middle is like you can't
get it
you can't get through like the texture
this is half yeah
[Music]
it's like way more intricate than how i
would do it just so you know
wait
yeah there's a marble
yeah there's like a little ball that
we're gonna like slam into it
pop it out and then you see like there's
a little marble in here and then you
take this and you just like
one two three
[Music]
or we just okay yeah that's on us
oh
this tastes like an airhead it tastes
like an airhead and it tastes like the
mystery flavor of an airhead and i love
it
so good mine tastes like sprite um
ramune uh it's great it's so good
obviously i'm a fan i always get it when
i go get ramen tell us
oh so with ramen yeah like like a
saitosaki this
ramen you're having a good day
i would think like maybe with like a
sort of like a different snack like a
dry snack like chips
i would drink it again look it's a
liquefied airhead i love it
[Music]
ramune
a lot of people are asking where to get
the viral hot pink chips i found them on
the wii up and just discovered these
green ones that are seaweed flavor they
look really crispy so i'm excited yeah
i'm excited too i really like seaweed
yeah
oh not really what but
it's on a chip it looks crispy i'll give
it a try all right okay let's try it all
right should we cheers
mmm fire
delicious i like it really truffley the
black pepper it like sticks out to me
that's really good i could eat that
whole thing i like the color it's a
beautiful green it is a pretty green all
right it's matcha green it is matcha
green oh do you like that i do like that
let's see all right all right
[Music]
i do like it but i like seaweed chips
like if you've ever had like the seaweed
chips out of a pack it was just like a
thing of seaweed i think i would prefer
those if i'm going for a seaweed you
don't like it do you want me to eat it
yeah that's all you do i don't know what
to like say about this fairy seaweedy i
don't even like taste this like seaweed
you want to taste the seaweed in there
i'm like trying to but i can't okay
there um it is like more mild than
eating like straight seaweed i feel like
okay then yeah that i guess that's why i
don't really taste it do you like it
yeah i like it a quick palette cleanser
ramune wait
[Music]
okay take a small bite
[Music]
oh my god no
um
okay no wait i get what you're saying
so we're eating perfume that is horrible
that is like one of my favorites wait
but think of it think of it as like um
like a candy kind of like
oh
that tastes like like eating soap why
does it taste like bananas
it just tastes like bananas why does it
taste like bananas there's a fruitiness
to it no but it's a banana flavor but
not a good banana flavor like an oh like
a stale laffy taffy banana flavor bad
yeah we're just we don't like that one
no the next flavor is purple yam and
coconut jordan's actually alert she
really did leave you don't have to
come back she's allergic to coconut so
i'll be the only one drying these that's
all you
wow
[Music]
smells like coconut
i got like purple like powder kind of
like
my head
it kind of tastes like the outside of
like a coconut shrimp but not as good i
wouldn't know what that tastes like i'm
realizing that now is i'm just
describing coconut with coconut i don't
hate it but i don't think i would choose
it out of all of these that's good i
like coconuts all of these except for
the seaweed i like all of them except
for the rose like that's like maybe my
least favorite thing i've ever really
yeah we're done okay i don't know
thanks guys
[Music]